meet Willie she's 82 but young at heart  and still going strong a burglar who  recently targeted her home in New York  State found that out the hard way he was  outside Sam please call an ambulance  because I'm sick I'm sick when he phoned  the police but before they could arrive  the intruder broke in I hear a loud  noise and I'm saying to myself what the  heck is that the young man is in my home  well the doors I'm alone and I'm old but  guess what I'm tough I took that table  and I went to working on him and guess  what the table broke if when he's down  I'm jumping on him he's laying down  already cuz I had we did a number on  that man it's at that point help finally  arrived and officers took the man to  hospital the hell did he expect to come  face-to-face with an award-winning  bodybuilder capable of lifting twice her  own weight as well as one-handed press  ups she hopes the story inspires people  of all ages and it's sure to scare off a  few burglars to keep Rachel  skynews